whose stories there was what did she
tell you the one about the red dress she
did not she did not what red dress
there was a photoshoot and all the girls
showed up wearing red I just but it was
who's amazed like World War 3 the the
the blowback lasted for about two weeks
oh yeah it sounds vaguely familiar what
are you wearing oh my god you said
you're gonna wear blue you said you were
wearing green so I thought it was safe
I'm sick of green you said you were
gonna wear blue I'm like a blue Sheila
popcorn
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
did you say it's been almost 30 years in
the intro no 20 you said 30 did I you
did yeah don't we do it cuz it hasn't
been almost 30 years since the show
started but really but that made me feel
terrible
[Laughter]
they were like 17 years ago you an idol
and I was like better my life is
exponentially it's so much I was saying
to somebody backstage because they were
talking about like their mid-30s were
the best and I was saying like I at at
the mid 30 like people start taking you
seriously and they they respect you a
little more and it's it's different it's
a different point in your life and now
I'm 46 and everybody takes me way too
seriously and here's actually the best
part so your Instagram handle is at
aren't you that guy yeah thank you for
so so I came up with are you that guy
because literally everybody goes wait
aren't you that guy and so I was like oh
that's perfect I'm not big on social
media cuz it's a whole different way of
like marketing and promoting things and
I just don't I don't play that way like
I Lala one of the women who I worked
with on on nano - I know she has almost
nine million followers on Wow and I have
like 300,000 and half of them are like
they follow me because of my wife and
she always gives me a hard time because
she she perm like she wears bathing
suits and does all these like you know
really good shots and then wow I have
pictures of like the ocean or benches or
trees and she's like this is why you
don't have as many followers because
you're a true photographer yeah they
don't get you so back so back to your
story so I had a woman in Vegas which
you were talking about chase me through
one of the casinos into an elevator and
she was like out of breath
can I take a picture with you like of
course you can sure so I took a picture
with it was really like flattering and
she was like thank you so much mr.
Timberlake you're welcome no yeah
totally
I said oh sure no problem in the doors
closed I never said anything to her
because this show was enormous like back
in the day you could not escape it right
years ago good friends like you know
friends got it this was friends back in
the day this is that kind of huge like
fun as its kind of get back and work
it's it's good it's surreal you know
we've we've had to do like photo shoots
and stuff for Fox and to be sort of
recreating these what they call iconic
pictures is is is crazy it's crazy a to
think that I'm in an iconic picture
because that just makes no sense to my
brain at all that's like every time
people talk about Idol and they're like
it was groundbreaking I'm like sure I
just wake up every day and try like what
are you supposed to say I you feel like
a tool either way anyway I love you ah
no thanks Idol so me yeah I do I
actually love I don't but um okay so my
producers this is I like to track down
some awesome things that maybe people
don't know okay Bryan and so we tracked
down this fantastic
[Applause]
where did you track that down you have
to investigate
do you still rap I don't you don't know
because I'm 46 and but I would hurt
myself if I did know people always ask
me to rap or dance and that's that's
like that great thing you want to dance
right now
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
do you know what this means people it's
just now I wear the cameras just making
it snow cuz we're not better what
shaking baby cuz I don't y'all Christmas
is my favorite holiday it's my show okay
so we're gonna celebrate Christmas every
month of the year
never gonna know when it's coming so to
kick off this month this month
celebration I have a little gift for
everyone
[Applause]
we have a karaoke machine in every one
of our green rooms okay and I start each
show with Kellie okie so we thought it
only appropriate that everyone in the
audience is going home with a papa bogey
all in one way I will not stop talking
until you subscribe to my youtube
channel that's right and I could talk a
lot seriously not gonna stop yep still
here not going anywhere I see you don't
walk away from this